so did you see that debate last night
did you did you did you did you man that
was just a slugfest bloody blood gushing
everywhere say you got yeah Bernie
Sanders who basically escaped unscathed
cuz everybody already knows he's an
octogenarian communist the only person
who landed a blow against Sanders was in
fact Michael Bloomberg the blow was
pretty solid but I think gonna hurt
Sanders in any serious way because
unfortunately Bloomberg was also the
target of attacked by the other
Democrats so all the Democrats are
idiots let me let me make this clear
on a political calculation level so here
is the political calculation for each of
the Democratic candidates last night
what they needed to do so Bernie just
needed to escape he's the front-runner
that's all he needed to do Joe Biden
needed to revitalize his campaign the
only way to revitalize his revitalize
his campaign would be to take Bernie
down a peg and that needed to happen in
Nevada and in South Carolina because
Biden attacking Bloomberg doesn't help
him all that much the reason it doesn't
help them all that much is because
Bloomberg is not on the ballot in Nevada
or South Carolina and if Biden does not
win South Carolina he is toast he is
done good by Joe Biden least successful
presidential candidate ever ever
seriously ever he's run three times and
not won a single delegate hey so that
was Biden's agenda so instead of
attacking Sanders naturally he attacked
Bloomberg and also it was nearly dead
then he had be booed judge so Buddha
judges job last night was in fact to
tear down Bloomberg and Biden and to
show outsized support in places like
Nevada and instead he got into a bleep
fight with Amy Klobuchar which is like
how did that solve any of his problem it
was sort of booty judges job to take
down Bloomberg and provide you know say
that he was the the moderate alternative
he tried to do it to his credit but he
was being dragged back down as honestly
I think that booty judge is the only
politically smart one among this among
this group because you have to
understand that people who judge had a
choice very early on everybody had this
choice there are two lanes in the
Democratic Party the intersectional lane
was quickly overridden by the socialist
Lane the Bernie Lane and the moderate
Lane need the Biden Lane Democrats had
to choose which lane you want to compete
in join a compete in the Bernie Lane or
in the Biden way now at the beginning
this is a pretty good question right
mean Biden appeared to be kind of
durable he was leading the national
polling
Biden a Bernie by the way I met Bernie
for his you know for all he was appear
to be a lot weaker I mean I understand
the calculation Buddha judge made these
strong and correct calculation that
Biden would prove less durable than
Sanders and he steered over into the
Biden Lane and as Biden collapse
who'da judge picked up that support so
Buddha judge made the politically smart
move last night he was attacking
Bloomberg he was attacking Sanders he's
trying to do all the right things but
unfortunately for him Amy Klobuchar was
right behind him with a Garrett so
Columbo charm was having none of it from
Pete because she made the same
calculation she's in the moderate Lane
too but she hates Pete and Pete hates
her that became obviously clear so the
two of them went at it meanwhile
Elizabeth Warren who is the dumbest of
all the candidates I mean truly the
stupidest in terms of political
calculation so she had made the original
wrong call the original wrong call was
go into the Sanders Lane not the Biden
Lane if Warren had gone into the Biden
Lane should be the nominee and said she
went into the Sanders Lane she initially
drew some support from Sanders then she
actually tried to effectuate his
policies which was an idiotic move and
then she collapsed then she just
completely fell apart
okay so last night on the stage she
decided that instead of attacking
Sanders who's in her Lane she was going
to attack everybody who is not Sanders
which again is dumb really stupid move
really stupid move
it's punching the horse and
Blazing Saddles there's no reason for it
at all that was Elizabeth Warren people
like oh she did a great job last night
no she did a great job in the same way
the chris Christie did a great job in
the debate where he murdered Marco Rubio
and then committed political suicide by
the way who predicted that yesterday
that was me I was right here saying look
for the ceremonial ritual murder-suicide
performed by Elizabeth Warren because
the media responded basically
recognizing that the debate last night
was complete cluster F and that it was
horrible for the Democratic Party I mean
truly bad for the Democratic Party take
for example Paul Begala and David
Gregory both Democratic analysts they
were like what in the world was that
nonsense this was a gift to Bernie
Sanders it was a rough night for Mike
Bloomberg man Elizabeth Warren just
gutted him like a flounder on Long
Island Sound
it was rough for him but Bernie did we
are two days away from the voting in
Nevada and they attacked a guy who's not
on the ballot in Nevada
it was I thought tactically
really dumb for the Democrats
strategically Donald Trump's gotta be
happy with the Democratic demolition
derby correct correct correct Paul I
mean public Iowa is right gotta give
credit to man when man is right Chris
Matthews was going after was going after
people who to judges like why are you
attacking Amy Klobuchar what does she
have to do with anything he asked Amy
Klobuchar this question like nobody in
the Democratic Party could understand
what are any of these morons doing on
stage last night it was it was clown
crashes while Bernie just stands there
unscathed hobbling his way toward his
Stalin desk dasha over over on Lake
Champlain is unbelievable here's Chris
Matthews O'Reilly they say come out of
the show come on in a rumpled talk to
Tucker Amy Klobuchar who went after
Peter the hatchet and then buried him
after wood chipping him up in North
Dakota in Fargo go they were going after
about Mike Bloomberg but for some reason
a Peabody judge went after a person to
his left here White House he pounding
you that is quite obvious Chris
we are surging and did much better than
anyone could have ever believed and I
think he decided he's gonna try to go
after me that's fine but I actually wish
he would have been accurate when he did
it but I will I'll deal with it
meanwhile meanwhile the rest of the
media they were just laughing at
Bloomberg because Bloomberg had an awful
night awful right his first 45 minutes
were terrible what happened to Michael
Bloomberg is that he came in and he
basically acted like he was embarrassed
to be there and embarrassed of his own
record then later he sort of Shedden
showed some light now maybe the debate
doesn't end up mattering all that much
maybe it turns out that Bloomberg is
able to spend his way out of this hole
but CNN bashing Bloomberg and they
weren't they weren't wrong he had a
rough night last night you have millions
and millions of dollars and you could
cut clips from this debate and you say
show the clip you show that show the
good clip where where he challenges
Sanders on his electability you can use
that in an ad one clip
they're all laughing in Bloomberg
because of course they're idiots and so
and so they're gonna make birdie that
Albany they're gonna nominate an old
commie all right guys
pick your poison
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
benton shapiro show if you did go ahead
and hit the subscribe button so you stay
up-to-date on all of our future content